-My first guest is
an Oscar winner starring
alongside Denzel Washington
and Rami Malek
in the new thriller
"The Little Things,"
which will be in theaters
Friday, January 29th,
and available on HBO Max.
Here is my man Jared Leto!
That's what
I'm talkin' about. Yes!
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
The applause is deafening.
They multiply it
when we air the show.
It sounds like
there's five people doing this.
-Oh, five people? Oh, nice.
That feels so good.
Just feels so good to be home.
-[ Laughs ]
Can you believe this?
The last time I saw you
was at the Met Gala.
The big Met Gala in 2019.
-Yeah.
-That was the last time
we saw each other.
And it was --
I couldn't believe --
I thought I've seen you
since then, but I guess not.
But it was very memorable
for me because, you know,
these Met Galas are giant
and everyone gets dressed up.
And all the money
goes to a good cause, you know,
and all that stuff,
for the Met Museum --
Metropolitan Museum of Art.
But everyone's dressed up.
I think the theme of the night
was camp,
and you carried around
your own head.
Uh, we have a couple of photos.
Can we take a look back
a couple years ago?
Look. This is unbelievable.
It was -- [ Laughs ]
It was -- Yo. My G--
What --
What was the inspiration?
Do you remember coming out
and going like,
"Yeah, I'm gonna do this"?
-I think there might be
picture of you and I,
or maybe you with my head --
I'm not sure --
somewhere from that night.
-Do we have one? Oh, yeah.
That's me, you, and your head.
-♪ Just the three of us ♪
-Oh, yeah. Then I pulled that
move, which was even weirder.
I've kind of put your head
where my head is.
-[ Laughter ]
-It was so fun that night.
Everyone was holding --
-Yeah, it was a blast.
I remember I walked
out of the hotel,
and there were
all throngs of people,
like, kind of greeting folks
as they left the hotel.
And I walked through the hotel,
and for some reason,
just held the head up to the
crowd, and they just roared.
And I thought,
"This is so strange."
I don't know what, you know --
I don't know what it was,
but it was just a weird --
It was a very weird thing,
but a very fun thing, too.
-You know, I thought about you.
I wanted to reach out to you.
But I figured everyone was
probably reaching out to you.
When the quarantine
first began --
and you probably know
what I'm about to say --
I couldn't imagine this
happening to me or to anyone.
But you didn't even know that
everything had been shut down.
You were on a retreat.
Is this true?
-Absolutely true, yeah.
It's like a two-week, roughly
two-week silent meditation.
The idea is that you go away.
You get rid of your phone.
You get rid of distractions.
You get rid of everything.
And you just meditate.
And when I went away,
there were about 150 cases.
Uh, and just in that
short amount of time,
when I came out,
it was shut down,
a state of emergency, uh,
and the whole world had changed.
But when we're in there,
they didn't tell us.
So we didn't have our phones.
There was no talking, of course.
-No TV.
-No eye contact. No TV.
Um, and the teachers
didn't really --
They made a decision. "Let's not
disturb the participants."
-Oh, my goodness.
-And I didn't turn on my phone
until I went back to LA.
So, I drove the whole way,
you know, trying to be,
like, peaceful and zen.
Keep the feeling going.
And I got back, and I was,
you know, kind of shocked.
It was like Rip Van Winkle.
-I mean, it's like
a "Twilight Zone" episode,
but in real life.
-Yeah, it was shocking.
It was a great --
I had this great tool
to kind of deal with "stress"
and things in life,
but I don't think anything
can quite prepare any of us
for what we all went through
at the beginning.
-No. Oh, my goodness. No way.
But I thought of you.
I go, "Oh, my goodness. I can't
wait to talk to you about that."
Because that sounds like
the most bizarre story.
-Yeah, it was like coming out
to the zombie apocalypse.
-Yeah, I got to say
you knocked it out of the park
for "The Little Things,"
which is coming out this Friday
in theaters and on HBO Max.
You did it great.
This is so good.
Dude, you're so --
The whole movie,
I'm just going like,
"Oh, no. Whoa.
This guy's so creepy, man."
It didn't even look like you.
Was that -- You had a fake nose?
-I had a lot of stuff going on.
Yeah, it was --
First of all,
I had an opportunity to work
with Denzel Washington,
one of my heroes.
For me, he's like
Brando and Beethoven.
-What was that like?
-He's just --
He's just, you know --
He's the GOAT. He's the king.
And, yeah, it was
a whole transformation.
I had different -- had
brown eyes, a different nose,
different teeth, a different way
of walking and talking,
and it was just this
super-immersive character.
-How do we describe the movie
and who you play in the movie?
It's great.
-Well, the name says a lot. I
play a guy named Albert Sparma.
And right from the name,
you can tell
he's a little different
and a bit of an outsider.
But I found him
to be really funny.
He had a pretty crazy
sense of humor.
It was a special one. Something
really special about this.
With Rami Malek and Denzel --
just to get in the ring
with those two guys was --
I felt really, really fortunate.
-I want to show a clip.
Here is Jared Leto
and Denzel Washington
in "The Little Things."
Take a look at this.
-I saw the "for sale" sign.
-That was for another car.
-Got a lot of miles on it.
You a -- You a salesman?
-[ Scoffs ] No.
-How's the trunk space?
-Standard.
-Mind if I take a look?
I'm in the market.
-It's not for sale.
-All I need to do
is take a look.
-You must really like my car.
-I do.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Jared Leto, everybody.
"The Little Things" will be
in theaters this Friday
and available on HBO Max.